welcome back to the Rich Eisen shown not
only to the listeners and viewers but
this gentleman who'd spent nine seasons
highly successful seasons as head coach
of the Carolina Panthers two-time NFL
coach of the year and a Super Bowl
champion in his own right as a player he
is Ron Rivera how are you sir doing well
rich thank you so I appreciate you
joining this program and let me just
jump right in with both feet
if you you don't mind were you surprised
by the conversation you had with David
Tepper when he said that he was gonna go
in a different direction with you Ron
yeah I was surprised that it happened
the way it did I mean you know it was a
great conversation oh it was it was very
respectful you know we we discussed the
whole situation sort of stances you know
and and at the end of the day I could
understand his his reasoning behind it
it just it made sense to me and you know
again it is the owner and and it's what
he decided in and but to be honest also
he was he was one to look at some
opportunities from my first time for
some of the coaches so you know I
understood it and so I got it but it
mean it was hard because the truth is I
I mean if I thought if it was gonna
happen it was happening at the end dear
well yeah I guess he did say that if he
was already beginning to want to get
feelers on who your replacement might be
he owed it to you to not have to here at
second or third hand that he was doing
something like that I guess
what he was saying exactly and and that
was probably the biggest thing was was
we talked about you know the hey he
wanted to you know throw some things out
there and kind of you know shake the
bushes a little bit he was out there and
I understood that and and one thing we
also talked about too is he said you
know every week if we lose the game rots
yeah you're gonna hear the hot seat the
hottie hottie that stuff to it quite
nothing he didn't think that would be
fair either so I appreciated that you
know I'm thinking about that well I mean
when I chatted with you in London prior
to your eventual win in in that London
game against the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
things were trending in such a terrific
direction with Kyle Allen at one point
you were five and three and then we all
know the four-game losing streak
happened do you think that had you eat
that one out in the Green Bay snow or
one
the Superdome that you'd still be the
coach of the Carolina Panthers right now
I think so I mean I you know there's a
lot of things happen that kind of led us
down this road and you know probably the
biggest thing where was I think the
attrition got to us you know the
injuries just kind of caught up I think
the more and more you know we we moved
forward and and and we didn't quite have
our office of lime set we didn't you
know we didn't quite have all of our
defensive linemen out there you know
those those things became became tougher
and tougher to compete and I think
unfortunately that's what got us at the
end because I'll tell you there's still
some guys playing some really dynamic
football when you put the TV on you know
you get a chance to watch Christian play
the way he has and DJ more and you know
Luke playing as hard as you can I mean
there's a group of guys that are just
giving everything that haven't you know
in the fortress not enough of those guys
out there that are healthy Ron Rivera
here on the Rich Eisen show and as for
the future again now that you're out of
the organization it is Kyle Allen a
viable starting quarterback for the
Carolina Panthers in your estimation for
22 million time I think in time he could
be a viable option I just think that you
know what's happened is the stuff that
he knew he did early on there's really
really well but you know the more and
more people saw him the more and more he
had to take onto his shoulders it became
difficult and people seem to forget he's
really a rookie right now I mean you
know lastly please started one game you
know and it really didn't take a lot of
snap still at the end of the year you
know this year everything was set up for
cam and and we had to kind of bounce
around and change things and he hasn't
had the same starting cast around so
again I just think that what time is the
only thing that could really tell but
you know he shows he's got flashes he's
got that ability to make place so I
think with time he can become a solid
viable answer for potentially a team
going forward but IIT is interesting you
say 4:18 because I just don't know if
Carolina's got the time with the
decision that they have to make with Cam
next year knowing the inside information
that that you perhaps were we're having
on cam do you think what do you think
Carolina's plans for Cam and 2020 are
going to be Ron well I think really
everything's predicated on himself I
mean he wouldn't had the foot
Seger done and you know it should be a
good recovery he's been working hard for
that I were I've heard and and again
knowing cam every time he's been truly
counted out he's always kind of bounced
back he's always founded and then just
come back even better so I really
wouldn't bet against him and again it's
all predicated on how that's what comes
along you he talked about how good his
shoulders finally felt that type of
stuff so again it looks like it's really
now about focusing on getting a foot
ready to roll so if he's healthy calm
March you think he's going to be the
starting quarterback of the Carolina
Panthers in 2020 well he will be ready
by March but I think if he comes back
it's an opportunity to compete he's got
a chance and he really does I like I
said I would never bet against cam cam
just one of those kind of guys that has
that kind of ability that you know and
when he gets rolling
I mean he's as good as anybody in the
league well I guess the only reason why
I said March is that's obviously when
the new league year hits and things need
to get paid and stuff like that so you
don't think he'll be ready when those
decisions get made do you what what
timeframe do you think based again on
your knowledge of the situation when you
think cam might might be ready to do
something like that wrong I just like I
said you know yet had the procedure done
and you know as long as that foot heals
up properly and you know and you'll have
to wait and see you know when they make
that decision Ron Rivera here on the
Rich Eisen show what about you what
about your future Ron
well what I'm hoping is get the
opportunity again to be a head coach in
this league I've been it's funny I've
been working working on preparing a
coaching book I've been preparing for a
number of possibilities out there and
just trying to get myself ready you know
looking through a list of coaches that I
know and coaches that are out there so
it's really just been you know over the
last few a couple of weeks really has
just really been about prepping and
preparing and just kind of staying
focused you know I took a week off from
football and really didn't watch any
football that first weekend but last
week I kind of watched a few games you
can't quit Ron you can't quit
you can't quit it come on oil come on
it's you know 33 years I mean it is hard
to just walk away and you know
completely turn my back so like I said I
got a chance to watch and got an
opportunity to watch some of the guys
play and it was kind of exciting to see
those guys go out and play as hard as
they did it gives themselves a chance
down the stretch so what did you do in
the weekend where you tap down a
football for the first time in 33 years
would golf I golf you know we have some
very good friends out here in Charlotte
and they all kind of huddle around us
and nearly they kind of took us out and
we went out to dinner and distracted us
on Saturdays you know went to a barbecue
and then on Sundays we got together with
a group of friends and we golf and we
hung out at the the 19th hole and just
kind of staying through it was
interesting was every it really was I
mean just how mindful folks are when we
walked into there they took all the TVs
and put them all on golf and basketball
and I mean seriously and we didn't ask
them to do is definitely I didn't ask
them to update right it's just I mean it
was new so mindful so respect for me
it's so typical of the Charlotte
community that we've been around and and
just the fact that they did that far as
I took out my mindset god it was you
know very thoughtful of everybody but
now now that said when you're playing an
on coaching football so do you still go
for it though I mean you're still around
the green you're like maybe I shouldn't
a flop shot this but screw it I'm going
for it yeah is that your game to also
run that's part of my game is you know I
come 10,000 miles to lay up so let's go
your River boating on the golf course
too is essentially what you're saying
yeah okay I need every shot to my you
know my wife's a single-digit handicap
nice she should give me no mercy she
crushed me I mean yeah I told I said
just remember you got build my
self-esteem back up babe I said look hey
look a competitor is a competitor
whether she's your your wife your
significant other or not so have you Ron
Rivera been contacted by anybody yet I'm
not asking for names but how have you
gotten in contact know what I've heard
is over a lot of behind the scenes stuff
this is what is what you hear
roundabout way you know somebody talked
to somebody I know that type of stuff so
you know it's just you know it's all
kind of clandestine right now and
everybody's kind of keeping things under
wrapping and respectfully so I mean you
know that's why I think you gotta kind
of keep it quiet
of course because again you know in the
same way that David Tepper said hey look
I want to be upfront with you I'm
kicking tires I want to kick tires on
other people I don't when you hear it
secondhand you're part of this coaching
fraternity here Ron right I mean the
fact that if you're starting crying and
pecking for gigs that means that
somebody else might be ah it's it's such
a difficult world it really is so
sensitive behind the scenes away from
everything you know that part I get I
mean and because again you know the game
is so competitive now that you've got to
be ready to go as soon as things happen
so all that said before I let you go Ron
Ron Rivera here on the Rich Eisen show
if you could you know obviously after
nine years and being through the
crucible breaking in obviously a highly
talented quarterback generationally
talented - I like cam going to a Super
Bowl with him being on the ups and downs
where he had a very difficult stretch
and then caught fire and you won
division championships three in a row
and a division that we all know as a
revolving door atop there all that said
you know what pit Falls would might
befall a coach and things of that nature
from ownership to situations what would
you choose if you could wave a wand and
say I want to coach again and I want
this situation what would your ideal
scenario be whether it's shopping for
the groceries all of that stuff what
would it be wrong it's a current roster
that the young roster has got a good
core I think a cooperative owner and
general manager that understands that
you know the 53 is it's got to be ours
you know it's decision we all going to
make become game day you know I think
the 46 has to be leaning towards the
court other coaches discretion
you know because again he's the one
that's going to be out on the field and
you want to make sure you're you're not
handicapping your coordinators as far as
the 46 is concerned so you know
again like I said I mean yeah I
understand there there's you know
there's there's a protocol into how
things go but you know to me you know
the 53 is got to be a collaborative
effort but the 46 really going forward
is really all about the game planning
and making sure the coaches have what
they need to come game day and then just
to put a blunt question to you you do
want to coach again yes oh absolutely
absolutely I believe you know it's funny
is this I told Stephanie I said you know
that the hardest hardest Sunday wasn't
the first Sunday at the artist and he
was the second Sunday because I actually
watched the games I probably hadn't
watch the games but I actually watched
the games on Sunday and that's really
when I kind of got a little antsy about
things yeah that's when you you missed
it is that a I wonder what the emotion
was wrong and it's funny because I'm you
know yelling at the screen and I'm
watching things you know and you know
we've got these these two new dogs and
they're just trying to learn and
understand us and Here I am yelling at
the TV for no reason and the four things
are yeah they're going outside they
don't want to hear it welcome to the
club of screaming at a football
television screen Ron welcome to the
club honey now I have a chance to say
what I want sometimes about what goes on
on the field you know and I could do
without getting in trouble
yes and you know it's kinda interesting
to be in that position okay and before I
let you go I do want to let you in the
position of being in the media the
paparazzi you have seen a ton of teams
this year the toughest team that you've
seen this year that you think it's
championship quality as a chance to win
the Super Bowl which one is that Ron
Rivera
oh okay I mean I'd lean towards
Baltimore right now I think what coach
Harbaugh and the staff is doing I think
what they found in terms of how to use
the quarterback properly you know
they're a team that knows how to get a
lead and exploit the lead and by that I
mean once they get a lead you can really
see the defense play I think the only
chance people really have against them
is that they can if they can keep them
from getting a good lead where they can
cut that defense loose but I find if I
was a betting man I'd lead towards
Baltimore now that said in the NFC so
wide open the last three road games you
coach
at San Francisco at Green Bay at New
Orleans which one of those three do you
think is the one with the best chance
well it's kind of funny if you look at
the best defensive the three obviously
is San Francisco the the best offense or
the most you know the one that really
seems to be racking up right now is
under Drew Brees is leadership and but
the guy that everybody says you can't
count out because he seems to find a way
as has been has been up in Green Bay I
mean what Aaron Rodgers has done you
know in terms of keeping his team going
and just the way he does I mean the NFC
so tough right now it really is because
it's very very competitive at the top
you know we know who the elites are in
the AFC but oh man again I I'm not gonna
say anything because who knows I mean
these guys okay or the Carolina you just
can't bring yourself to say New Orleans
it's just maybe that's it could be that
no you know I got so much I have so much
respect for what Sean Payton has done
there I really do I'm headed up to watch
him up close for nine seasons and you
know even even when they were down the
way they played the way he did things
they were always competitive and that's
that's what's so hard to pick against
New Orleans right now but gosh I hate to
count out really good defense I hate to
kind of you know a dynamic quarterback
like Aaron Rodgers who just never know
well Ron I appreciate the call and I'm
not saying this just because you have
called in this show for as many times as
you have and I've met you as many times
as I had at the NFL network as well as
this show but you know teams that would
be very well off should they knock on
your door and decide to get you off that
golf course Ron and I look forward to
seeing how this all plays out for you
well I appreciate that
who knows when it'll happen early and
you know we get working again you got to
take care of yourself Ron all right you
got it that's Ron Rivera right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on Br
live or download the Rich Eisen show app